JOHN ESSIGMANN: I work in
the field of genetic change.
In a perfect world,
you would say,
guanine would always
pair with cytosine
and adenine would always
pair with thymine.
It turns out, however,
that sometimes chemicals
from the environment can react
with our normal nucleotides
and change their coding
characteristics so
that mistakes are made when
polymerases try to read them.
These are mutations,
and mutations
cause genetic diseases.
My role in the
field of toxicology
is as a person, who is both
a biologist and a chemist,
who studies how chemical damage
to our informational molecules
is converted into
changes in coding
that results in genetic change.
I'll emphasize,
of course, this is
the basis for all
genetic disease,
but it's also the
basis for evolution.
In other words, mutations
happen naturally.
That means that we're not
all-- we don't all look alike.
And that means there's
diversity in a population,
and that's because of mutations.
And evolution is a
really good thing,
because if we were all alike
when the environment changed,
then the chance of extinction
might be very high.
If there's diversity
in a population,
that's actually a hedge
that life uses in order
to be able to make sure
something's going to survive,
because some members
in the population,
while they may be
considered quote
unquote "weaker" in the
initial environment, when
the environment changes--
they're the ones, for
example, with hair on them,
and survive the global
winter that happens
after the meteor strikes.
So, we are interested
in chemical modification
of DNA and RNA as it relates
to the causation of disease,
but we're also
interested in the rates
at which genetic change
happens in a population,
and how that's a good
thing, and that it provides
for the continuance of life.
One example of our
work in evolution
comes from recent work that
we've been doing on HIV.
When a virus infects
one of our cells,
our cells respond by trying to
limit the growth of the virus.
They try to kill it.
And one of the
strategies that used
by what's called our
innate immune system
is to induce a number
of enzymes that start
to rip apart the DNA bases.
They really take
the amino groups off
of cytosines and
adenines in order
to try to convert them
into non-coding nucleotides
or miscoding nucleotides.
What happens is, if
you take a cytosine
and you take away
it's amino group,
it makes it into a uracil,
and then, rather than
pair with a guanine, it'll
pair with an adenine.
Because these are
enzymes that kind of move
along the viral genome,
they create a huge number
of mutations.
The process is called
lethal mutagenesis,
because what happens
is, eventually
the number of mutations
is so large that you
can no longer
produce a functional
protein or nucleic acid.
That's a natural
strategy that we use.
And thinking about
this, some years ago,
given my lab's
expertise in knowing
about the structural
modification of normal bases
that makes them
mutagenic, we wondered
if we could contaminate the
nucleotide pool of a cell
with mutagenic nucleotides
that would force a virus
to mutate even quicker.
HIV, it turns out, almost
goes extinct, but not quite.
In other words, our innate
immune system, in one day,
creates every single point
mutation in the virus,
but it also creates every
single drug-resistant variant.
And it just doesn't
push hard enough
to be able to push the
virus to extinction.
So, we wondered whether-- if
we could push a little harder
by using creatively
designed molecules--
derivatives of cytosine,
that would pretend sometimes
they're a cytosine and sometimes
they pretended that they were
a thymine--
that we could push the
virus over the top.
And we found that
it did work, OK.
In other words, we were
able to push the virus
to a technical state
of extinction using
our understanding of the
chemistry of the molecules
that the cell has the capability
to use in replication.
It may seem unwise
to intentionally put
mutagenic chemicals into
people, and, obviously,
we worked out a strategy to
prevent mutations in people
in the drug design process.
Specifically, it turns
out there are pathways
called DNA repair
pathways that repair
damage in our nuclear genomes,
and they happen in the nucleus.
That's where the
enzymes are located.
It turns out that the early
stage in HIV replication
involved replication
in the cytoplasm.
There are no repair
enzymes in the cytoplasm.
So, the virus has no defense
against the mutagenic affects
of these compounds.
We picked compounds
that, if they
were to get into our nuclei--
it turns out that our
polymerases don't like them
very much, anyway, but
if they did get in,
they're very rapidly repaired.
So, it creates what we call
a therapeutic index which
is very favorable in
favor of killing the virus
but not putting mutagenic
chemicals into us.